uh last session of the day
um before i introduce miguel i want to
mention that mark olivia the previous
speaker is available for hire
if anyone's looking to give him a job
he's on the market for next year um
miguel is a group leader in ikoki um and
he's going to tell us about
a way to calculate things
which involve an arrow of time
another speak about something that um
say i didn't really have anything in
this topic right i may contributed a few
years back but lately i'm working on
other things and this is the closest we
have and it's still a work in progress
uh but we already got results i think
it's exciting enough uh to to share them
and um i also would like to get some
some feedback especially because i think
that i cannot believe that i'm the first
one to come up with these ideas
so let's start
at some point in my life i was working
in three problems i thought that they
were completely disconnected and
recently we discovered actually that
they form part or their variance of a
sort of super problem or meta problem
and we then we found the solution of the
problem but i'm going to speak about
only one of them
which was this one it's a really weird
problem well actually it's very natural
but it is what is that nobody has
considered it before
so if you start with a finance state
automaton this is simply some
some
system that has some internal state that
can take fairly many values as name
indicates
and then it has an external input also
that belongs to some finite alphabet now
when you input something to this
automaton two things will happen
well first of all the internal state
will change
and also it will produce some output and
how
these two elements will change will be
given by this probability distribution
will be a conditional product
distribution on the initial value of the
state and the input and this will
determine
well not determine it would give you
some distribution on the on the final
state and also the the outcome
the server based network is is actually
quite kind of value to to draw so these
are the two observed variables and this
is these are just latent variables right
i mean one of them is the internal state
and now these two form a sort of
transient thing that generates both the
internal state and the output
if it was just this it would be really
boring right i mean something that you
input something and you get some result
it could be a calculator
but the good thing about the automata is
that you can uh you can iterate the
process right i mean suppose that you
start with an automaton in some state
sigma one we put some symbol y1 and we
get some output and also there's a
transition
but now we could do the same right and
then we put a second symbol and then we
get a second output
and so
when we get tired then what we have is a
collection it's a list of outputs and
also a list of inputs
now if you consider what is the the
correlations the correlations are sorry
the the product distribution of this
outcomes condition of the inputs then
you have what people in lisima field
that we call temporal correlations
and of course if i gave you the
transition matrix of the automaton and i
gave you the distribution of the states
initial state you could calculate this
obviously right i mean very very simple
and again a service network is for this
conference right i mean but it's kind of
kind of similar right i mean you see
that as a clear hour of time right
and meanwhile you get some some
statistics
and of course i'm making the assumption
that
whatever functional relation is
generating these two variables based on
these two it's going to be the same one
over and over
in this paper we how weird it says the
color it should be blue
where is it
okay so according to these papers uh we
will deposit problem of characterizing
the set of correlations that you can get
using a dimensional automaton
and
well it's kind of easy to see that if
the dimension of the automaton is is big
enough then essentially you can qualify
whatever you like and whatever you like
means you can generate any correlation
any temporal correlation that satisfies
the condition accommodation call set of
well no signal into the past similar
input to the past means that the input
that i put uh in the future cannot
affect the statistics of the outcomes in
the past which makes a lot of sense
right i mean you cannot expect to go to
go beyond this
but the interesting thing is when when
this this number this d is actually
below this value then it's a it's a
really complicated problem to
characterize what kind of correlations
you can get with one of these automata
you an idea what kind of things these
people are interested in
in this paper these two papers the
authors consider a scenario in which the
automaton has actually no input it's
actually a hidden markov model you can
think of it but more or less it's not
exactly the same
and the this automaton is that it's
going to be transitioned between the
states and outputting some bits and we
wish the automaton to put
n minus one consecutive zeros and then
finally a one
i want this because it's a model i could
model what an alarm clock is something
that waits for n minus one seconds and
then emits a signal
of course if the dimension of this
automaton is smaller than m you won't be
able to lose it with certainty so this
automaton may produce the sequence but
only with some probability because this
is what is the maximum probability
the limit on the amount of the number of
states of the automaton what is the
maximum probability that we have of
producing this sequence
is not a complicated problem but nobody
has considered this process in the past
it's very weird we really want to really
old books of
computer science right i mean there are
lots of material about finance and
automation but this kind of problems
like optimizations of automata but i
couldn't find them before
okay so let's think about what this
problem entails
so uh oh sorry i i have to also for the
motivation actually if you go to the
paper uh you you realize that more than
finding the actual value of this this
quantity you want to know what is the a
good upper bound so recently good upper
bound for this
because uh now
i'm not going to get into the physics
okay but the thing is that the same way
that i define a classical automaton you
can define a quantum automaton
where and is only for the physicist
the internal state of the system is is
codified or represented by uh by a
d-level quantum system
and the the thing is that if you go to
the label you build this automaton and
then you observe that the probability of
getting the one tick sequence is greater
than any upper bound that you could find
on the classical value you can claim
that you go to a quantum advantage
which is exactly essentially what my
field is about my field is about proving
quantum advantages
and for that of course you need an upper
bound
another problem
so if you expand it the way the people
in in optimism theory like it would be
exactly this these are the variables of
the problem these probabilities and also
this probabilities here you want to
maximize this this expression is a
polynomial so it looks good it's a
polynomial polynomials are nice or
they're all friends
and you can you can you can realize that
actually you can get rid of these
variables because you can always assume
that the automaton starts in a given
configuration and by symmetry you can
take it to be number one it doesn't
really matter so in the end it's only
these variables wait that's how that's
that's really complicated already
because these are these these conditions
here define some convex set of possible
values for the variables
but the problem is that this objective
function is not concave so if you try to
apply standard methods like reading
descent you will probably get run stuck
in some local maximum
and of course if you go to the lab and
you get this value and if because you
don't know that it's a local maximum you
just know that it's the value that i got
in my computer but now i go to the lab i
i read the one tick sequence i can
create the probability and i thought it
is greater than this it doesn't mean
that we have certified a quantum
advantage it is something that is
probably an upper bound of this value
here
okay so now of course there are methods
uh people have come up with methods in
optimization theory to to get upper
bounds for this kind of optimization
problems
and the problem is that all these
methods
scale really badly with the with the
degree of the polynomial and discuss the
db of the polynomial is the same as the
the number of uh of um
time steps
so it's really bad right i mean you try
to use standard methods and you start to
predict what happens and when you have
two ticks which is not very testing
okay there's an extension of this
problem because if you think about how
you count how do you verify that you
have the sequence zero zero zero zero
one you could in mind that i see that
that another automaton is very fine that
the first automaton where you where
you're optimizing is actually producing
this sequence so you could consider
there is some optimization where you
have a you want to optimize for a
d-state automata
an adjective function that is determined
by interactions of this automaton with
some non-automaton
this would be a bit difficult too but
it's not difficult look we just take the
automotive that we control then we input
some symbol then we get an output and
then we fit the output to the input of
the automaton where we which we want to
optimize
now it produces an output the output
will fit into the input of the automaton
we control we get another output and so
on and so forth
and at each point because this part we
can control this automaton we can
control we can implicitly open it and
see accept the state so we can associate
like some sort of score for its possible
value of the state
and the goal will be to maximize this
this is called on average right i mean
there are possible automata that you can
have here
because this part that is solar
automatonistics right this is actually
the definition of the problem
if you want some example then the things
simple i could think of is suppose that
for some reason you're interested in
finding what is the maximum average
score that you can get in street fighter
using a distinct automaton so this could
be controlling ken and then you could
use the capcom fight engine to control
rio and then you want to see what is the
maximum you can do without a three three
bit automaton probably is terrible but
but i don't know i don't know the answer
and i bet that you don't know either
right i mean why because we don't know
how to solve these problems
so to solve this kind of problem we
meant it uh some sort of formalism
okay but i'm going to do this sort of
meta problem that we will over
that allows you to formalize that
pronounced root
okay so a sequential model is is uh is
some system that has an internal state
and this is going to transition and well
we'll speak about this later it also has
a city some sort of penalty and the
penalty depends on the state but also
depends on non-evolution parameters you
will understand why i call them
evolution parameters and some
uncontrolled variables these are
variables that don't really have a
distribution
it doesn't really matter you're ready to
to actually do three wheels in in a
sense right i mean these control values
are going to to conspiracy against you
and you will you'll understand in which
sense
okay now there's a transition and this
transition is meditated by some known
equation of motion that so the new state
will depend deterministically on the
previous state on these
unknown variables and control variables
and also and these unknown evolution
parameters
and we we assume that this this equation
of motion actually could be time
dependent so it depends on which time
state you are i mean it will have this
transition and even the pro the the very
definition of a state could depend on on
which time step you are in
now like with an automaton you can also
iterate operations on one of the
sequential models you will get some
sequence of
penalties
and the the goal is to maximize what is
the the sum of all these penalties over
all possible values of this this
variable here and the unknown evolution
parameters and also over all possible
values of these and control values that
you have at this at its time step
now if i removed this variable here then
what you would have is a is a markov
decision process it's something known
already in mathematics and
[Music]
yeah but
i will speak more about this
okay so how does it fit with the problem
that i give you before right i mean
we're thinking of optimization so we're
finished automata this one here
over uh
uh some function that depends on on this
interaction with each other
automatically how do you how what does
this have to do with sequential models
we have to find some uh subsequent model
that is associated to this kind of
scenario
[Music]
if you're dealing with uh this is uh
transmission models this is the most
obvious spread one of the models would
be the reproduction number of the virus
you don't know what it is
so it's an unknown evolution parameter
and it is the same at its time so it's
the same for each box
okay so we're going to formulate this
thing as a sequential problem right and
what has to do first is to find some
subsequent model that describes this
interaction between these two things and
easy to do there are other things
actually more efficient but interesting
to do is to to take a state of the
system the priority distribution
over these three variables the input of
the first the automaton which we want to
optimize the state of the automaton and
the state of the automaton that you
control
is going to be our state the state of
the sequential model
and if you take this satisfaction for a
state you see that indeed you can
develop an equation of motion given
given the state sorry given the state
that at a given time you can use some
parameters that are always the same so
these are the
parameters and some of the parameters
they already know because they're
defined by the problem in order to find
the next one the next state
and in this case we don't have really
these different control variables in
this case it is a particular variant
there are those especial problems i
don't have time to speak out anything
but i was trying to solve them and when
i started investigating this one of them
is the problem of detecting entanglement
in a spin chain notice only for the
thesis but it will be it will be very
very short
and you have a lot of spins you have a
lot of quantum systems and then you want
to do a one and a half cc measurement we
want to measure each of these systems
one by one and at the end you want to to
make a guess whether the whole state is
separable or not
okay there's one problem that you can
also formulate as a sequential problem
and another one is a problem actually
where you don't have this non-evolution
parameters so in principle you can think
of it as a markov decision process
but the problem is that the standard
methods for a market decision process
are not suitable for this kind of for
the kind of problems that i have here
so you have to use the techniques that i
will tell you now
and the other one and actually this is
one in which you have really all the the
non-evolution parameters the dynasty
variables etc is the problem of bounding
the cost of a government policy for
disease control
i could formulate this mathematically
but i don't really wouldn't really have
time and you're curious i can i can tell
you later but but
it's actually the
the most important thing of
okay so
how do you solve these problems so i'm
going to give one method
um
okay this is the original problem we
want to solve we want to maximize the
total reward of
the values of these variables here
and we're going to introduce a function
and it's going to be a we call it a
value function
it will represent the maximum penalty
that you incur into from 10 k onwards so
all the cumulative things cumulative
penalty that you will get from 10k
onwards condition on the current state
being sk and on the value of lambda they
are non-evolution parameters
it's a definition
with the definition then you can make an
observation so the maximum penalty that
you will have at this moment for in the
future is equal to the penalty that you
will have now plus the penalty that
you'll have in k plus one times which by
definition is given by v k plus one pk
plus one acting on the next state and
the next state is a function of the of
the p of the current state this um
uncontrolled variables and also this
lambda lambda variables here so all you
have to do is to maximize over the
unknown and control parameters and then
you get the new the new function
so you can define all these functions
in principle
again
if you drop this
this
uncontrolled sorry these are
non-evolution parameters then you end up
with
what is called the bellman equation
okay so one more method to solve this
kind of problem is precisely to take
advantage of this observation suppose
that we want to minimize the minimum of
some real number mu
and the condition and u is greater than
the value function for for the first
time step
and then uh
with these constraints right i mean
namely that the the whatever function we
have in the case the step is going to be
greater than the the penalty plus the
function of the next time step evaluated
on the next state and this has to be
true for all possible values of these
variables of the of the
control variable also for all possible
values of
of the non-evolution parameter
so if you follow the sin of inequalities
you will convince yourself that actually
any value any value of mu that's that
that is feasible as this by these
constraints so for which there exists
functions like this right i mean does
this fight this constraint it will give
you an upper bound of the solution of
the problem of the sequential problem
and if you if you choose these things
this v
v v 1 to v n to be the
value functions of the problem then
actually you will get exactly the we
will be equal to the solution of the
problem so this is actually another
reformulation of the original problem
what is the complexity of this
reformulation well it will depend on how
difficult is to optimize our functions
which is impossible something difficult
right and how difficult it is to enforce
these constraints but whatever the
complexities of these two things as long
as you can bound it the total complexity
of the algorithm will be n the number of
time steps times this complexity it's a
linear
and you're not going to get better than
this it's really really the best scaling
you can you can
hope to hope to get
now um i mentioned that well this method
based on value function there's another
method that is another formulation of
the original problem that is based on
the
optimization of our marginal probability
distributions i'm not going to speak
about it it's very interesting to to
derive it or to show where it comes from
right i mean but i won't speak about it
because actually these two things are
the dual of each other
so you regard this as an optimization
problem it is a complex optimization
problem in fact then you find that the
dual you build the lagrangian then you
find that the dual of this problem is
actually this one and vice versa
but sometimes it is good to bear in mind
this other formulation because it gives
you some intuition about how to how to
tackle the problem we don't have enough
computational resources
okay now there's a problem with this
formulation because well that's two
problems
this problem is that you're optimizing
our functions and this is very difficult
i wouldn't even know how to do it
actually unless unless these taste can
only take fairly many values or
something but but we're speaking about
states that can take a continuum of
value so it's really complicated
optimize our arbitrary functions
and the other problem is that well i
will speak out their problem later but
the first problem you can read about
very easily all you have to do is to
optimize over some subset of functions
that you know how to parameterize and
the simplest thing that i can think of
is the set of polynomials of degree to n
because in this case you only have to
take care of the coefficients so it is a
finite dimensional optimization it could
be very difficult but it's finite
dimension
it's a big problem even if these things
are polynomials to certify that one of
the dominates the other
this is really complicated in general
but in any case even if you could solve
this problem then
because your optimization over a smaller
class of functions
then you will get you you want to be
able to reach the minimum in general so
you'll get an upper bound of the
solution of the problem
but the good thing is that polynomials
can approximate whatever
so this
sequence of upper bounds as then goes to
infinity should combat the solution of
the problem
so it's it's a it's a well okay it's
just because of how paramount is
converging again it's difficult to
certify this part right i mean so that's
why you weren't trying to solve this
either but now what you two do is in
order to satisfy this inequality use a
positive stellan sats now positive
telling sets is some really nasty german
word that means that
we have some criteria in the extractable
that allows you to certify that these
faults
this is a sufficient criterion but it's
not necessary so it means that something
say it doesn't maybe that they satisfy
the criteria sorry this actually holds
but you're not able to prove it okay
but uh
well because now we're optimizing over
the set of functions such that this
thing is not only is totally true but
parallel you can also detect them with a
positive still instead
then you're getting even another upper
bound of the solution of the problem
but if you choose your positive stances
in a clever way then
nonetheless in the limit the sequence of
operons will convert to the solution of
the problem now this positive cell in
satsa there are many in the literature
some of them depend on which one you
take this problem will turn it into a
different problem in complex
optimization for these two for example
you this problem will turn into a
semester program
sort of optimization over supposedly
some efficient matrices that we know how
to solve
the features there's another another
another more exotic um
positive telling set that uh that if you
try to apply to this problem would
transform the problem into a pronoun
geometric optimization which is a bit
more complicated and also there are
there are others
applications
so let's go back to the original problem
that i posted before
we want to maximize the probability that
this did automatically outputs the
one-pick sequence
this paper the office what we did it was
was to consider epsilon nets of the set
of possible automata right i mean you
can parameterize probability and write
them and then well they have to do
really lots of crazy things you know to
get these numbers right i mean but they
might manage to get the the optimal
values the optimal values of this
probability for for dimension two
you have to use uh really complicated
computers a cluster and parallelize
everything but i managed to get it okay
using the method of value functions
together with smoothness positive steal
and set
then we managed to reproduce all the
numbers
in maybe one hour
with a with a laptop actually with this
laptop
um
now in the paper they do something else
they they managed to get some guesses so
what are the maximum values for other
automata with higher dimensions in this
case they couldn't make epsilon nets
because as dimension increases
the obviously becomes exponential in the
dimension it's really terrible it's it's
a drama so what i did was to use
gradient descent in order to get these
numbers but of course they're not sure
whether these numbers actually the the
the optimal right i mean it's a
conjecture these things are
actually the maximum value that you can
achieve with this data automata
well using the same method but this time
with a big computer it is this thing
died at some point then we managed to
get to reproduce this value and we must
we might also go to to get numbers for
the other ones but they were
higher a bit higher than the numbers
that these people reported and it is not
clear who is right or who is writer
right i mean it's not very clear uh
it's very clear whether our bounds are
strict upper bounds or or or on their
hand they're actually the real bounds
and these people just couldn't find it
because they were using a somebody's own
method
but unique is the fact that you can
recover everything in dimension 2 shows
that
if you start studying the the value
functions that are output by the
computer right you will be able to
derive a general formula and then they
saw the problem analytically
and i count on you
okay
okay entertainment detection is pinching
i will go fast because i know that some
of you don't know physics i maybe don't
care right i mean so this is only for
physicist it will be really fast okay so
we want to detect entanglement in a spin
and one way to do it is to to take a uh
a phallistic automaton and then we saw
this automaton will tell us that it's
time how to measure its particle and
depending on the outcome it will tell us
how to measure the next particle and so
on okay and at the end of the day you
you follow this progression and at the
end of the day
based on the final state of the
automaton and the last measurement
outcome you make a guess
whether the the particle was where the
whole system was entangled or separable
okay so we came up with some entitlement
detection protocol for the headsets the
the
different numbers of well it is kind of
trivial to see that jet set will will
you will we will get the entangled
tag with probability one and the problem
has to was to compute what is the
maximum priority of declaring entangled
sulfide that is actually not entangled
and this this request optimization over
several states which is really nasty
it is obvious to get a lower band of
this maximum which is one over two but
apart from that with the annoying
fields this is what i got with actually
with this laptop again
and
this is an upper bound that i got using
this other formulation that is based on
prior distributions that i didn't want
to talk about
and
you can see that uh well it it very
quickly it goes for for high end to to
something that must be really close to
well it is really really close to the
optimal value because we have a lower
bound which is equal to 0.5 the
interesting thing about this graph is
that i managed to go to n equals 40 with
the laptop
yeah
n is the number of particles in the in
the spin in the spin chain
no this is one copy now there's a copy
and you get a probability you have to
repeat it several times you need to
decide right i mean it's it's
interactive right and you do have
several preparations
yeah always because yeah the product is
still 0.5 right i mean but you don't
have to take that many right existing
low enough
as i said is this number and because
just so you have an idea
about here it will be what i would get
with a normal computer or maybe with an
xmd computer well maybe that with a
computer the size
of okay the size of spain right i mean
here i would be able to get something
with with 15 systems right i mean the
complex discrete exponentially so if i
now went to here which is in brute force
then i would need the
10 to the 20 computers of spain right i
mean so it wouldn't work
but
again i got this with this laptop right
i mean it's not it's not special it's
not magical anything like that right i
mean i didn't get it from a street story
shop where they said it was the devil or
something oh it was it was it was
something that you can get
now the next step is to complicate the
problem so suppose that we take the
psychological model and then we add a
policy
a policy essentially something that you
can control okay then it's going to
affect both the penalty and also the
equation of motion
remember the goal of the sequential
problem is to maximize the total penalty
to get to the worst case scenario which
is the worst penalty that you can get
this was a problem with valiant policies
that the goal is to minimize the over
the set of policies what is the maximum
penalty that you're going to get
now this is of course unrealistic
because just computing this for a given
policies is very very complicated but
more realistic goal is to
is to try to minimize some upper bound
on the solution of the sequential
problem
because in this case if you have a solve
this problem then you will have a policy
that you can go and implement
and also you will have an upper bound on
the maximum parity for following the
policy which is good right i mean you
can say ah look ellie if you go to a
shop and then you steal a sandwich then
you will get
incarcerated for two years right i mean
you know what is the maximum penalty
right i mean you know the policy you go
to the shop and you steal the sandwich
right i mean something that you can you
can apply in your everyday life
don't do
it
okay so we're thinking actually about uh
about the the
the disease control problem
uh yeah the idea way to go to the
government with a goal with a control
policy so some policy that as uh you
have to declare confinement these days
and under these conditions and then you
have to vaccinate the people like if you
follow this this this policy strictly
then at most the number of yearly debt
is going to be this amount
okay now the way to solve the problem
but this is a really complicated thing
so i'm going to be extremely an original
we just saw that we propose to solve the
problems to use gradient methods
so if you have this function or you have
to do this to starting from some sub
guess on the optimal policy then you
update it sequentially using the
gradient of this function you can use
this method which is what people call
vanilla in machine learning and you
could use adam which is something that
wouldn't fit in this in this uh slide or
it was much more complicated that uses a
momentum and stage like this right
uh which is what we will propose the
problem of this thing is how to
calculate this this is gradient because
it's not trivial
because okay this is a real problem but
we relax it we relax it in a in a
complicated way right
and relax into an optimization problem
and
then it's complicated to calculate the
gradient of of some the solution of
something optimization problem right
well in this in with the paper that is
to appear right i mean we consider a
large class of relaxations of the
original problem and then we find that
you can calculate actually you can
calculate the the gradient and there's
some mild assumptions about what uh what
the properties of the
minutes are
there's a mile assumption for the
properties of the optimal solution you
can calculate it
and the the bottom line is that the
complexity of computing the grade is
comparable to the to the problem of
computing actually the bound
so you have enough computational
resources to to put a bound on how
the maximum penalty that you have enough
computational resources to optimize for
policies
okay so
for the future and this is the part that
we haven't done yet but we're we're on
our way we like to try to completely
automatize the entanglement detection
protocols that is that you give me some
you give me some reference state that
you want to detect the entanglement then
i conduct some optimization over uh
protocols
that have the property that they will
declare it separable the reference state
with very low probability and
at the same time they will whenever they
say that it's entangled and the state
happens to be separable this would
happen with very very low probability so
exactly one of these problems that you
can also formulate in the the way that i
saw you before is one of these this
optimization server policies in in
sequential models
and and we we're thinking of replacing
the definition automaton by a recorder
neural network
because i think uh i think it's easier
right i mean well it looks more
practical right in a recurring neural
network the state of the system internal
state is given by a continuous vector
instead of just simply some some
discrete value and probably this gives
you much more flexibility and also it
allows the the machine also to output
some input that is also continuous which
is good because the measurements that we
do in the laptop so actually depend
continuously on some parameters
and of course we still have to do this
part but the process is extremely
complicated to to try to make some sort
of software to or at least to try to see
how the algorithms work for for this
control i don't have this latest idea
what kind of things we can get i have a
paper that i forgot to
to mention here exactly about this kind
of things where we try to do everything
done rigorously so in the end you got
you got a sort of lower one you got a
lower one actually on the number of year
leaders but of course you cannot go to
the government with if you follow this
policy
it could happen that you kill one
million people but no they want to know
for sure right i mean i want to because
otherwise it's ridiculous
and i'm going to stop here thanks
here we go questions
um you mentioned the bellman equation
development question uh where what why
what is that uh this is an equation that
appears in in this markov decision
processes
yeah so this is like this you have a
scenario like this but you don't have
this this lambda here
and this is pretty much it it's
something that people have studied in in
mathematics right and we used to yeah
it's also used to model things that
change in time and the problem with the
automaton is that it didn't work because
it's something that is always the same
at every point right i mean which is in
this case the transistor matrix of the
automaton so for the problem that
inspired the whole thing this formalism
wasn't good enough
and i think is that normally in order to
solve the development equation
but my equation is
if the number of possible states
and the number of possible um
control the the call actions right i
mean control values the values of this
variable are finite you calculate this
thing exactly because it's just a finite
optic message affirmatives are family
possibilities so you have a couple of
things
exactly right i mean in in in our case
we're interested in continuous things so
most of the um
the literature and the topic does not
help us
yeah at the end you are considered
continuous state automata essentially
yes that will be our recurring neural
network can't that defeat anything i
mean the whole point it seemed to me in
the beginning was that if you have a
finite state then there are some
tasks which it cannot possibly succeeded
other than with reasonably low
probability and now you have the
possibility of finding a quantum
advantage because the classical system
will do very poorly whereas the quantum
system will do maybe probably but much
better at achieving the probability of a
chance but if you have a continuous
internal state how do you start
happening you can codify everything i
guess right i mean
so
why are you looking to generalize to
that
yeah no because i the the original thing
was to to show that uh if you go to the
lab and construct a finished automaton a
quantum one right and you have you can
do magic right you can do better than
classical so for that we need to focus
on the this automata and the techniques
that i shot also work for continuous
automata i pray that you know what is
that
i guess you know you need to make some
assumptions right there because you know
whatever they don't think there's any
limits right i mean
you could assume that the functions that
determine the transition are kind of
smooth or whatever and probably then you
will get some non-trivial restrictions
i guess
and and lastly you uh
when you were doing optimization number
functions you chose to look at
polynomials of degree two n yeah uh was
the two sort of arbitrary like it's just
something that you can
take an asymptotic limit of like y2n
y2n and not n we mean or already
understand okay okay
well it's because yeah it's because if i
if i um if i fix the the the degree
right i mean then
the whole function can be defined with a
fine number of coefficients and if i
don't then so i wouldn't even even know
how to start the optimization if i
didn't have this information if i don't
if i don't restrict the functions this
way
but there are okay i have to say
i mentioned this this word the horrible
word the positive telling sets they also
post positive stella and depth
correct yeah okay
for um for functions that are not
polynomials and this is really curious
they're positive student sets for
functions that are linear combinations
of exponentials and then you
you can the the the coefficient multiply
the exponent and also the the exponent
itself
maybe they may they have some
applications
other questions
i think this is a bit connected to the
discussion um
in the case of general quantum supremacy
um
people
you know it depends a lot on what the
task is right i mean sure
sure hit on something that's really
important because cryptography depends
on not being able to factorize right
but the fact that you can do so much
better
in a quantum context
is
very deeply embedded in the mathematics
of what you're calculating and so you
started out with your alarm clock right
i mean that's a very simple problem and
it's kind of interesting to think about
from a quantum point of view if you had
stuff bouncing around and you could have
different kinds of interference and
maybe you know the interference would
clear after some time and you get a good
probability for tunneling um
but is there some i mean that
was that problem chosen just because
it's easy to state or is there some idea
that here are some problems where
a quantum
finite i mean if
a quantum thing like this could do much
better than a classical thing like this
or you know
some class of problems that look like it
now you know i understand the whole the
whole uh the whole the the the original
reason why they consider this kind of
things was because it appeared naturally
it's this problem when you try to use
quantum systems to measure time because
at the other day everything is quantum
and but they wanted to see how how well
you can do with a given dimension when
you have only control of a given
dimension and this is a really
complicated problem and and
i don't know actually to come to think
of it maybe they were maybe it was not
very important to to
to find the maximum priority for the one
click sequence on the on the on the
classical uh version but more on the
quantum version but with this technique
you can also do it in principle we
haven't done it but i'm not sure
mostly you can do it it depends on
whether the computer is able to to has
enough memory to to carry the first
steps if it does probably it will
go through and if not
thank you so much
i